The first rough plot
of the Mandelbrot Set
appeared in a 1978 paper
by the mathematicians Robert Brooks
and J. Peter Matelski.
Soon after, Benoit Mandelbrot,
a researcher at IBM
who had access to more computing power,
also discovered the set.
This led to further explorations.
These early computer graphics were crude,
but the patterns revealed the presence
of something far more complex.
Even with fuzzy
poorly made pictures
in the eighties
they were able to really glean
a lot of interesting insight
into what's going on.
Mandelbrot went on to popularize his now
eponymous set to the world
and became known
as the Father of Fractals.
Today, mathematicians
can use computers to explore
the Mandelbrot set
in far greater detail.
And as soon as you have images
it just opens up
this whole world
people didn't know about.